Speaker 1: Michael Flynn used to be national
security adviser. He was national security adviser
for a relatively short period of time
to the former president, Donald Trump.
And Flynn has been caught on video saying about
a rifle that he was gifted, that maybe he'll find
someone in Washington, D.C., to use the
rifle against. This is the very same
former Trump national security adviser who was
indicted and later pardoned by Donald Trump.
Flynn has been appearing at various events across
the country and he did one at a California church.
I don't know what about Flynn makes him good
material for church appearances. I don't I
admit I'm not like an expert in the teachings
of Jesus, but something about this guy doesn't
strike me as good material for a church. But
specifically, this was at the Church of Glad
Tidings in Yuba City, California. They gifted
Flynn an assault style rifle. And then Flynn
made the remark about maybe I'll find somebody in
Washington, D.C.. Let's take a look at the video.
Speaker 2: That's awesome. And
tell us about your yeah, yeah,
so we were trying to come up with a rifle that
we thought was appropriate for a general, so we
went with the old school woodland camouflage. So
anyhow, this is one of our top quality guns and
maybe I'll find somebody in Washington, D.C.. Oh.
Speaker 1:
And the crowd cheers about maybe finding
someone in D.C. with his new shiny rifle,
consider the level of humiliation that this
country is enduring globally thanks to the
vestiges of the prior administration. Donald Trump
continues to insist that he won an election that
he lost and the world laughs. We continue to
struggle to get people vaccinated because of the
anti vaccine sentiment that exists overwhelmingly
in Trump supporters. And the world cries because
it affects everyone. And now Donald Trump's own
former national security adviser, Michael Flynn,
gets a rifle as a gift and says, maybe I'll find
some people in Washington. And the world is aghast
that what is taking place in this country.
Rachel Vinland, the wife of whistleblower
Alexander Binmen, was among those who rightly
denounced Flynt on Twitter. She said that Flynn
should be recalled to active duty and court
martialed. Retired four star General Barry
McCaffrey last month went after Flynn because,
remember, Flynn recently called the Myanmar like
called for a Myanmar like coup in the
United States. At a Kuhnen conference,
McCaffrey said this is putting the country at
risk. I have never heard anything like this
in the last hundred years. This is completely
irresponsible, provocative language. And quite
frankly, if this was anybody but who, it is a
former Trump administration official. But if
it was some random guy, I suspect the FBI or local
law enforcement would be immediately investigating
comments like this. This is the guy who encouraged
chants in front of crowds to lock up Hillary,
lock up whoever he's done more to warrant being
locked up than they have by far. And if you were
Flynn, why would you ease up on this stuff? Right.
I mean, you were convicted. They had you dead to
rights and then Trump pardons you. And before
you know it, you're traveling around the country
getting gifts and getting paid for bogus speaking
appearances, churches, of all places. It makes
sense. If you were Flynn, you would be feeling
emboldened. And by the way, speaking of churches,
why is that church tax exempt? Why is any church
tax exempt? Maybe churches that raise money to buy
gifts of guns should not be tax exempt. Now, I've
talked about this before. I understand that when I
say churches shouldn't be tax exempt, some people
get mad and they write to me and they say, David,
churches do education and schools are tax exempt.
Churches sometimes run soup kitchens and charities
for the homeless and those are normally
tax exempt. Why would you take that away?
I have no problem with the church run
soup kitchen as a standalone enterprise,
keeping its own books and being a nonprofit, even
though it's a religious education. I don't even
really have much of a problem with a church
run preschool or kindergarten being organized
as its own entity and getting nonprofit status.
But a blanket you pay no taxes on real estate.
You pay no taxes on income because that's really
what it is. It's income because you have claimed
to be a religious entity under the law that
has to go. And it would be a real gold mine of
government tax revenue. We could fund all sorts
of important things that people love to say,
but how would we pay for that? The Washington
Post estimates this is an eight year old estimate.
It's probably a higher number now that the US
could make about eighty five billion per year
by eliminating subsidies on churches
where they get to pay no taxes. That's
real money with which a lot of good could be done.
And it's just it's all backwards. The Michael
Flynn thing is backwards. Tax exempt churches
is backwards. It's all completely backwards.